Russia's invasion of Ukraine has brought
death Devastation and unspeakable
suffering
we all remember the horrors of butcher
Russia must pay for its horrific crimes
including for its crime of aggression
against the sovereign state
and this is why while continuing to
support the international criminal court
we are proposing to set up a specialized
Court backed by the United Nations
to investigate and prosecute Russia's
crime of aggression
we are ready to start working with the
International Community to get the
broadest international support possible
for this specialized Court
Russia must also pay financially for the
devastation that it cost
the damage suffered by Ukraine is
estimated at 600 billion euros
Russia and its oligarchs have to
compensate Ukraine for the damage and
cover the costs for rebuilding the
country
and we have the means to make Russia pay
we have blocked 300 billion euros of the
Russian Central Bank Reserves
and we have Frozen 19 billion euros of
Russian oligarchs money
in the short term
we could create with our partners
a structure to manage these funds and
invest them
we would then use the proceeds for
Ukraine
and once the sanctions are lifted
These funds should be used so that
Russia pays full compensation for the
damages caused to Ukraine
we will work on an international
agreement with our partners to make this
possible
and together we can find legal ways to
get to it
Russia's horrific crimes will not go
unpunished